this is the day that we used to call
black monday but the reality is we know
a lot of these openings before we even
get
to monday the jets fired adam gase last
night we were expecting the hammer to
fall with doug marone i i wonder whether
or not in the hierarchy of shot khan's
wish list
doug marone
is high enough
that he wants to know
he's going to get the guy he wants
whether it's urban meyer and i think it
is urban meyer one chris right urban
meyer is talking too much
to other people for that not to be sure
the presumption urban meyer won
and then isn't marone two is it if i
can't get meyer i'll keep marone how
many guys are there before you keep
marone but i think i think shad khan
recognizes that you don't throw out the
guy you have
unless and until you know that the guy
you hire is going to be better and i
think that's why marone's still on the
job well i i understand that i mean
there's a there's a lot to like about
doug marone you know again i i don't
look at
jacksonville the last few years and look
at them and think they're an
ill-prepared bad badly coach football
team do i think that you know their
roster is you know influx it's young
this year of course there was what did
anybody expect from doug marone this
year i mean come on really what did
anybody think was going to happen
so
all right yeah i don't know i do still
have faith in him and i think overall as
a football mind i i believe in a lot of
things he believes in but i just i don't
know i i you know with the way it's
looked the last few years you're gonna
have the number one pick for trevor
lawrence and
there's guys like we just talked about
eric b enemy and dave ball out there
that are going to be hot commodities you
know you have a chance to kind of get
one of those combinations of like hey an
andy reed with a special quarterback
this could be fun to watch and i think
that's got to be you know on their radar
as well
right but but urban meyer seems to be i
know very very tough and he would have
the ability to hire a gm i mean they're
ready to give the guys the keys to the
car he's never driven at the nfl level
and you know a lot of the great college
coaches look at nick saban i mean
what you do to make you great at the
college level may not necessarily
translate for saban it was and still is
an incredible gift for recruiting and
that's one of meyer's strong suits
recruiting recruiting recruiting well
you can't recruit at the nfl level he's
going to have to put an infrastructure
in place where he he gets players that
that are good enough that they can be
coached by him into superstars and you
know if he does take the job
this whole trevor lawrence justin fields
thing right out of the gates fields is
the guy he recruited to ohio state but
lawrence is the clear-cut top prospect i
i'd be stunned if urban meyer doesn't
take trevor lawrence and i think for
business reasons the jaguars need a guy
like that who's going to resonate with
the fan base and yeah and sell very well
and from george well when they go over
there it's yeah
but but it's just one of the dynamics to
consider if meyer gets the job but i i
think they're holding on to marone until
they know
what
what is going to happen and because i
think there have been times where maybe
teams regretted getting rid of a guy
before knowing
who was going to take the guy's place
you always want to have it all planned
out yeah and i just think hey we're
going to fire this guy who are you going
to hire well i don't know we'll figure
that out that may not be an acceptable
position for shot khan no i i think
you're i hear you and i think between
the tom coughlin thing and maybe
caldwell not living up the expectations
there that that might have given you
know given given marone a little bit of
a fighting chance here despite his
record and everything like that um so
that it'll be interesting to see again
they were competitive and tough in every
football game we saw this year and none
of those games did we ever think they
really should win that game going into
it so there is something to be said
about that marrone's a good head coach
i'm a believer in jay gruden as an
offensive coordinator you know there's
things they'll like down there in
jacksonville to where yeah if they did
stand pat i don't think it's crazy and
last thing i'll say with this
conversation
urban meyer would scare me to death i'm
just like ultimate respect
you know other than nick saban the
greatest co college coach of our era no
doubt about it but like
i i just
i i've seen him in two other stories
get tired get stressed out and leave so
now he's older and we think that's gonna
change why he's if you hire urban meyer
as your head coach you're getting him
for three or four years and then he's
gonna retire and either go on to the
next project or he's gonna be done
forever and that's to where i would
question that hiring just a little bit
anthony lynn's status is
for the most part unknown because the
chargers have tried to be very
respectful i mean when you read the tea
leaves i think you come to the
conclusion he's going to be fired and
they've just
they've just decided to not leak
anything let him get through the season
and then we'll make the official
decision and implement it he's got one
year left on his contract that's not
much of a buyout it's a great
opportunity for them to go out and hire
an a-list coach to work with justin
herbert and a lot of the problems with
the team fall on anthony lynn period so
i think we can put him and marone in the
expected to be fired category and leave
them there and see how it plays out
chris yeah i think so too it's
unfortunate man do i like anthony lynn
man are there some good things about you
know their football team and what
they've done too
uh but i think you said it right you
know i think you just you look at the
way they lost so many games this year
there's no other way than to look at it
just go well i that's the head coach you
know the managing of the clock and some
of those things and everything like that
yeah and then of course hey we had the
special teams failures all of that and i
know that's not all anthony lynn but
it's under his watch and it is tough
there's no doubt about it and i don't
think it helps that you have a
guy like justin herbert now where you
know honestly everybody goes and just
goes whoa we got something special
maybe we need to try to go that route
with a coach
to
elevate you know specialness into
mahomes and rogers-ness to where now we
got a guy that takes over football for
the next 12 years and i think that could
ultimately hurt anthony lynn as well
yeah i i agree with you i think it's
just a matter of time uh and uh marone
and lynn are the ones we're watching
another one to keep an eye on zach
taylor in cincinnati there'd been a
report that he's expected to be safe i
it's it's not entirely settled at this
point i believe he could be back should
be back would be back the bengals don't
like to pay people to not work that's
been their mo so if there's any buyout
involved that that benefits taylor's
quest but 6 25 and 1 over the last two
years not great and uh you know i i i
have a feeling he's going to get another
year chris seems like there aren't i'm
looking for like where else and we get a
surprise
there was a stretch we were getting a
surprise every year i i don't see one
this year which which maybe lays the
foundation for a good surprise if we
don't see one i know i mean you know i
don't know i don't i don't see one out
there either unless you want to throw
mike zimmer out there again so he could
call you i don't see you at some point i
don't see you at the owner's meeting and
threatening to beat you up
you can throw it out there no i wouldn't
do that i wouldn't disrespect mike
zimmer like that i wouldn't do that
so i just just having fun but you're
right i don't know if there's anything
out there i think that zach taylor's the
one that i look at and i just i had
heard too that if he wasn't let go and
stayed there that you know they're gonna
force changes with on the staff a little
too but you're right anything other than
that
i don't envision anything else happening
mike it could be just all about you know
the two teams we talked about phil that
detroit lions the houston texans the
atlanta falcons and see where it goes
i think the one team whose fan base
would most most love to see a change is
the dallas cowboys but that's not going
to happen either they're not going to
fire mike mccarthy but i know cowboys
fans are up in arms yesterday with some
of the decisions that mccarthy made as
he wrapped up his first season with the
team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports